when you look at empirical tests  of the machiavellian perspective do you  believe that you should lie and  manipulate and hurt others to rise in  power what you find  is those people don't do as well in  organizations today  they don't do as well in american  politics you know the the classic  machiavellian was  uh president nixon who's now rated as  one of the least effective presidents  uh by historians and we've even done  studies showing they don't  do as well in finance in one of the more  machiavellian contexts so  you know what i argue in the power  paradox is  it might be time to abandon that  philosophy of power it's been wildly  influential  i think it's i think it's at the source  of a lot of today's  environmental and social ills